Let's go next to who else do we want to go to? How
about, oh, you know, who was on? Let's go to QandA
from Toronto. QandA, what's. What's going on?
Hi. This is actually Shawna from Toronto, Ohio.
OK, I assumed I assumed it was
Canada. But it's not. No. No.
I realized after I put it in it,
no problem, it's still allowed.
OK. Well, I just wanted to kind of talk about
the stimulus package. Sure. A situation.
So I live in rural community in Ohio. A
lot of people are laid off. I know a lot
of people have a lot of opinions about the
gas and oil industry, but it's big here.
And people have. And that industry is just dead
right now. Yes. So people are really struggling.
And it's just so disheartening to hear that,
you know, maybe it's a possibility. No stimulus
package until February. Is that what do you
think about that? Is that what's going to happen?
It is completely plausible, yeah. We earlier in
the week, we reviewed Nancy Pelosi's interview
with Wolf Blitzer where she lost her temper
with Wolf and started attacking him. And really,
you know, she's right to be frustrated. But the
frustration shouldn't be with Wolf's questions.
It should be with with Republicans and
Trump, because you would think, well,
listen, if Trump really is willing to do one
point eight trillion, why not take it on?
Nancy Pelosi's argument is it doesn't actually
really deal with X, Y, Z. The counter would be
we'll get the one point eight trillion to people
now before the Senate goes on vacation. Then we
have an election than we've got until January
inauguration and it could be February. But I do
think that it is completely plausible that there
will be no more stimulus money until February,
if at all, if by February there is if unemployment
ticks down another couple points by February
and the vaccines that's being distributed,
there may be no more stimulus money.
That's that's also a possibility.
Yes, I thought that, too, because if it
takes too long, maybe maybe they won't care about
it so much in February and beyond that next year.
So, I mean, listening might be amazing if
you didn't need a stimulus in February,
but people are going to be so upside
down on, you know, credit card payments
and housing payments and everything by then that I
think it's unlikely that it wouldn't be necessary.
Yeah, and, you know, we live kind of close
to West Virginia and they, like half the
people there, can't afford their rent. Right.
Right. It's it's bad. It's very bad, QandA.
Because, you know, again, the gas
and oil industry is there. Yes.
And, you know, everybody's all happy, you
know. Low gas prices and everything else.
Well, yeah. I mean, I know local gas prices
when there's nowhere to go. Don't do that
much for you. Low gas prices when the cars
and repossessed. Don't do that much for you.
Yeah, that that's exactly what
what my thought is on it. You know,
just. It's it's rough. It's rough. And, you
know, people say we'll just go get a job.
Well, it's kind of hard to do that
when you don't have any place to apply.
It is indeed. It is indeed.
QandA. All right. Thank you so
much. I appreciate hearing from you.
We are going to go to a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going to have the break is going to feel like
nothing. To the people on hold. And we'll be
right back on and take more of your calls.